madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
hinault poulidor thévenet thévenet
polidori no à moins qu'il ne s'agisse de
merckx ou de mehrtens robert chapatte
vous l'a dit il ya quelques minutes les
postulants au titre de champion du monde
sur route de cyclisme sont actuellement
en seul non loin de caracas au venezuela
il est 20h et 55 secondes très
exactement et nous devrions actuellement
recevoir les premières images de ce
championnat du monde
nous allons essayer caracas est bien
loin jean-michel le lieu où est ce que
l'on peut faire déjà un premier point
oui un point sur une image fixe mais
j'ai bien l'impression que quelques
coureurs vont quand même passer ici
devant notre écran pendant sept petites
minutes au cours de laquelle je vais
forcer vous dire ce qui s'est passé
depuis le départ c'est à dire depuis 15h
cet après midi ça fait cinq heures de
course 89 concurrents avec deux forfaits
d'importance peau lankais qui s'est
fracturé la clavicule gauche et hier van
impe également cela fait deux belges
alors que dire berthe remplaçait
volontiers au sein de l'équipe belge
il faut signaler que ce parcours de 255
km et hérissée de côtes à fort
pourcentage au total 68 km à escalader
et l'on dit que c'est un parcours plus
dur que celui du week-end ardennais
précisons également le nom des favoris
cuyper knetemann race et hotmail pour la
hollande moser pour l'italie leader
unique puisque baronchelli est tombé n'a
pas pris le départ
bureau pour l'allemagne mais qui voit
depuis début de course disparaître ses
équipiers il a des soucis à se faire
thévenet hinault poulidor et
danguillaume pour la france merckx
martens de blâme un gode frotte pour la
belgique
que s'est il passé depuis trois heures
de l'après midi il a fallu attendre le
60e kilomètres pour voir la première
attaque signée par roland des vendée
nous qui a été repris par cureau puis
ensuite une escarmouche avec poulidor et
fugace notamment que c'est un suisse et
poulidor a été repris par le peloton au
centième kilomètre démarrage d'un
français laurent puis ensuite du
hollandais race alors que laurent été
repris et finalement d'après les
dernières informations c'est très
difficile d'en obtenir jusqu au
venezuela
cette manne le hollandais serait en tête
pour l'instant avec une minute d'avancé
sur un peloton de 35 hommes groupe et
aux figures tous les français voilà pour
les dernières informations en provenance
cristobal huet bon dieu parce que vous
avez pu le remarquer sur cette image les
caméras sont placées bien loin bien loin
du circuit est donc bien loin des
coureurs dans le département de
l'ardèche
la chasse à l'homme s'est poursuivie
aujourd'hui gendarmes et policiers
tentent de mettre fin à l'épopée des
deux hommes qui les 24 et 25 août
dernier en tuer donc deux agriculteurs
près de pont de labeaume et blessé
grièvement un gendarme dans la même
région
une enquête difficile où les indices
disons où les présomptions l'emportent
actuellement sur les preuves tangibles
au chapitre de ses présomptions de ces
indices la disparition depuis plusieurs
jours de l'animateur d'une communauté la
communauté de roche baisse en haute
ardèche pierre conti c'est le nom de cet
animateur est recherché par la police
les enquêteurs souhaitent l'entendre
aucun mandat d'arrestation a été lancé
contre lui même si dans cette région la
rumeur publique l'a rapidement fait
passer de l'état de témoin au rang de
coupables sans preuve
je crois qu'il faut encore le dire ce
soir à périgueux un certain nombre
d'électeurs avaient aujourd'hui à se
rendre aux urnes dans les écoles pour
une élection cantonale partielle une
élection qui certes n'est pas un test
national mais qui permettrait tout de
même de savoir si la progression de la
gauche réalisés lors des dernières
élections municipales et lors du premier
tour de cette élection quand elle
dimanche dernier se poursuit j'attends
les résultats de cette élection diminue
la dhr d'une minute à l'autre pardon
avant la fin de ce journal
en tout cas et puis les conseils
municipaux avait à désigner aujourd'hui
les grands électeurs qui le 25 septembre
prochain vont élire un tiers des
sénateurs des élections importantes à
quelques mois des législatives puisque
le sénat dans le domaine constitutionnel
notamment sera peut être amené à jouer
demain un rôle tout à fait capital dans
la politique française
les sénateurs sont élus pour neuf ans le
renouvellement s'effectue par tiers tous
les trois ans
les départements dans lesquels aura lieu
l'élection cette année sont dans l'ordre
alphabétique ceux du bas rhin alion s'y
ajoutent paris les départements d'île de
france ainsi que trois départements
d'outre-mer au total lors des élections
du 25 septembre
il y aura cent quinze sièges à pourvoir
dont 107 pour les départements
métropolitains 6 pour l'outre-mer et 2
qui représentent les français de
l'étranger alors que pour les élections
législatives
les candidats doivent avoir 23 ans au
minimum
le candidat aux sénatoriales lui doit
être âgé de 35 ans le corps électoral
est également différent puisque les
sénateurs sont élus au suffrage
universel indirect
c'est à dire par un collège d'électeurs
qui sont eux-mêmes désigner directement
ou indirectement par le suffrage
universel
les grands électeurs chargés de procéder
au renouvellement du mandat des
sénateurs sont les députés les
conseillers généraux et les conseillers
municipaux ou leurs représentants dans
les villes de plus de 30 mille habitants
les conseils municipaux élisent aussi
des délégués supplémentaires à raison de
un délégué par tranche de 1000 habitants
arrivent le jour de l'élection
proprement dite dans les départements
qui ont droit à plus de quatre sénateurs
l'élection se fait à la proportionnelle
c'est le cas de paris où douze sénateurs
seront désignés par les 2399 grands
électeurs c'est le cas également cette
année du rhône de la seine maritime de
la seine saint denis des hauts de seine
et du val de main en revanche dans les
départements pourvu de moins de cinq
sièges de sénateurs
c'est le scrutin majoritaire à deux
tours
qui est appliquée le copain d'ordinaire
les renouvellement par tiers du sénat
nature pour beaucoup de commentaires
cette année ce n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose j'ai l'impression que
beaucoup d'hommes politiques attendent
ces résultats avec une impatience non
feinte
eh bien oui parce que c'est le premier
renouvellement depuis les élections
municipales qui ont été marqués par un
succès de la gauche en particulier une
progression du parti socialiste mais je
ne pense pas qu'il faille s'attendre à
une sorte de bouleversements ce n'est
pas tout le sénat on a vu tout à l'heure
qui est renouvelée mais seulement une
partie de ce scénario qu'hier
et puis il ne peut pas y avoir de
changement de la majorité de majorité
oui socialistes et communistes ne
totalise pour l'instant environ le quart
des sièges des sénateurs tout le système
électoral du sénat qui vient d'exposer
tout de suite et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
ce but c'est d'empêcher qu'il y a des
raz-de-marée sur le palais du luxembourg
si vous me permettez cette image les
vagues politique arrive devant le palais
du luxembourg au petit pas élevons leur
train de sénateur le parti socialiste le
principal vainqueur des élections
municipales a quand même quelques
chances de devenir le premier groupe du
sénat s'était jusqu'ici les centristes
mais tout porte à croire que demain
comme aujourd'hui le sénat correspondra
à ses acidités giscardienne d'une france
qui serait gouverné au sens alors
justement est ce que monsieur giscard
d'estaing ne sera pas peut-être obligé
au lendemain des prochaines élections
législatives de s'appuyer plus sur le
sénat qui ne le faisaient avec les
autres presser les présidents de la
république le lombric et c'est possible
et il est possible que le sénat donc
prenne un rôle un peu plus important
dans l'avenir que dans le passé vous
savez que le sénat a eu un certain
nombre de mes aventures sous la vème
république il y a eu à partir de 1962 la
longue brouille entre le général de
gaulle à et monsieur gaston monnerville
président du sénat et qui m'aiment
évitait de se serrer la main lorsqu'ils
se croisent aidants et des cérémonies et
puis il ya eu la tentative de refonte
complète du sénat en 1969 mais au départ
de la cinquième république vient des
commentateurs considéré que cette
république était une république
sénatoriales donc attache énormément
d'importance au sénat c'était par
exemple le cas d'un juriste éminent qui
était aussi un homme politique marcel
près l'eau aujourd'hui décédé qui avait
écrit un livre à l'époque dans lequel il
expliquait que le sénat forme et avec le
président de la république avec le
premier ministre une masse de granit sa
prévision ne s'est pas réalisé mais
peut-être pourra-t-elle se réaliserait
en partie demain si le président de la
république était en face soit d'une
majorité d'opposition soit tout
simplement d'une majorité qui ne
conviendrait pas tout à fait à ses
désirs et l'on sait en particulier
que le sénat est nécessaire à toute
révision constitutionnelle or monsieur
mitterrand avait annoncé il ya quelques
mois qu'un des premiers soucis de la
gauche à son arrivée au pouvoir serait
précisément de demander une révision de
la constitution
le copain les élections sénatoriales
sont pour le 29 septembre pour la
semaine prochaine et ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à des déclarations à des
faits politiques importantes et bien la
semaine prochaine sera encore une
semaine pré électorale mais cette fois
ci une semaine pré électorale
législative dès demain les formations de
la majorité se réunissent à nouveau
cette fois ci pour mettre en principe un
point final à la rédaction de leur
manifeste manifeste qui sera soumis
ensuite aux différentes instances des
formations de cette majorité et qui sera
présenté en principe le 8 septembre par
monsieur soissons à monsieur bahar et
puis du côté de l'opposition
il y à demain la diffusion assez massive
d'un document par l'humanité à 6
millions d'exemplaires ce document c'est
le dossier de l'actualisation du
programme commun vu par le parti
communiste avec un article de monsieur
marché déclare en particulier résume en
un peu le point de vue du parti
communiste sur l'ensemble de cette
affaire des progrès ont été réalisés
mais des divergences demeurent elles
sont sérieuses et nous aurons un des
exemplaires de ces six millions
d'exemplaires pour notre journal de
23h30 ce soir tout le monde sait que le
chômage existe mais certains motifs de
licenciement sont parfois ils restent
parfois obscures ainsi le bourg de saint
symphorien de lay dans la loire est en
train de vivre une aventure peu banale
une femme exerçant la profession de
travailleuses familiales rurales a été
licencié pourtant son travail consistait
à venir en aide à domicile aux mères de
familles aux personnes âgées dans la
difficulté et jusqu'à ces dernières
semaines
madame denise de michel c'est son nom
madame de michel remplissait ses
fonctions à la satisfaction de tout le
monde jusqu'au jour où certains
s'aperçurent que madame de michel
n'étaient pas mariés en clair qu'elle
vivait en concubinage résultats une
partie de la bourgade a pris position
contre elle et l'association qui
l'emploie la licencier bien que la vie
privée reste tout de même encore le
domaine réservé de chaque être humain il
était une fois dans la loire un village
sans histoire ça ça faut rien de laid et
puis un jour sur une boîte aux lettres
venant souligner sans passer devant
monsieur le maire
celui d'une aide familiale rurale denis
michel qui passait de faire ma maison
faire le ménage s'occuper des enfants et
celui d'un homme
la cendrillon du village avait un
compagnon mais les pantoufles des aides
familiales sont rarement trouvé par les
princes charmants
celui là est un ferronnier d'art sans
travail alors quelques familles se sont
émus de cette union libre
le travail de denise est jugée
irréprochable mais la sanction est
tombée ou le départ ou le licenciement
on m'a proposé une place dans notre
village mais moi en me précisant que je
n'habiteraient pas dans ce village et
que les familles n'y aurait pas me
demander mon certificat de mariage
sur quelle a été votre première réaction
ma première réaction a été de partir car
vraiment je ne pouvais pas le maître ça
ma deuxième réaction quand j'ai réfléchi
je dis que c'était pas possible de
partir que c'était prouvé que j'étais
coupable que j'avais quelque chose à
cacher alors que moi j'ai une vie privée
normal
et j'ai dit que je restais affaire va
prier que je n'acceptais pas leurs
propositions aujourd'hui denise de
michel et donc sans travail licenciés un
comité de soutien s'est formé pour la
défendre
car il n'est pas prévu dans les statuts
de l'association d'aidé familiale la
possibilité d'un licenciement pour
concubinage alors on justifie cet acte
par des termes vagues des ampoules et
son éthique personnelle n'est pas
conforme à la déontologie de la
profession
mais l'association qui l'a renvoyé nous
répond en fait qu'à l'écho d'une partie
du village qui se donne le droit de
juger sa conduite
ce licenciement sa de le village en deux
chaque clan distribue même des tracts
sur la place de l'église
quant aux responsables de l'association
il se retranche derrière les familles sa
vie privée je le répète ne nous regarde
absolument pas ce n'est pas la raison
majeure de son licenciement elle a quand
même été licencié à cause de sa vie
privée elle n'a été licencié à cause de
sa conduite de sa vie privée
c'est un fait d'après les familles
usagère de l'aide familiale étant donné
sa situation peut-être justement il y
avait peut-être certain statut moral un
euro à respecter difficile d'être
travailleuses familiales en vivant avec
un jeune homme
et puis madame d'abord faut-il savoir si
c'est un jeune homme est ce qu ont
librement la ville clé comment ça c'est
un jeune homme je crois qu'il est en
instance de divorce
oui elle donc c'est pas le jeune homme
mais est-ce que cela vous choque
cette attitude est oui mais enfin madame
la famille qu'en faites vous
il ya jamais de familiale qui vient
d'être licenciée parce qu'elle vivait
avec un jeune homme qu'en pensez vous si
cette seule me tue c'est un peu ça j'ai
récemment fait que c'était caché par
exemple aurait pu avoir un amant ou même
plusieurs
elle ira l'ont retrouvé dans un bois
coin gâchée même sa chatte est
premièrement elle est libre elle est
libre donc on n'a pas la licencier pour
ça votre avis sur que non c'est pas une
raison valable et ça je vous dis ce que
je pense moi que vous n'aimez pas comme
ça mais sous son esprit clochemerle
cette affaire pose un problème grave
celui de l' influence de la morale sur
la recherche ou le maintien de l'emploi
avec un nombre élevé de chômeurs c'est
peut-être une tentation pour les
employeurs de faire leur choix en
fonction des qualités professionnelles
les aussi de la vie privée dans ce
village très pratiquants on a mis en
avant la morale pour justifier un
licenciement
oubliant peut-être une qualité une vertu
la tolérance
chacun écoutez l'avis de l'autre et en
fonctionne cela se remettre en cause et
peut-être se remettre en cause une
décision qui avait été prise hâtivement
l'essor de 2002 michel se tranchera
peut-être devant la justice il à saint
symphorien de l'est la morale de
l'histoire est simple quand deux pigeons
s'aiment d'amour tendre rien ne sert de
séné il faut se marier ratant le
maréchal tito 85 ans vient de passer une
quinzaine agité reçu à moscou la semaine
dernière le chef de l'état yougoslave
est en effet arrivée à pékin mardi après
une escale à pyongyang la capitale de la
corée du nord
accueil courtois en union soviétique et
chaleureux très chaleureux en chine
l'ex-enfant terrible du mouvement
communiste international n'a peut-être
pourtant pas totalement réussi dans ses
tentatives pour rapprocher les deux
frères ennemis l'urss et chine
détroit capitale qu'il a visitées au
cours de son long voyage c'est
certainement oui pékin que
titouan reçu l'accueil le plus
spectaculaire accueil triomphal sur le
plan protocolaire donc a débuté dès
l'arrivée ici à l'aéroport et qui n'a
pas baissé d'intensité tout au long de
la visite officielle aux yeux des
chinois titouan apparaît comme le
symbole de l'indépendance vis-à-vis de
moscou
d'autre part l'affluence du leader du go
cela dans le tiers monde et pour pékin
d'un intérêt primordial car par le biais
de cette influence
il pourrait se permettre de mieux
contrer la politique soviétique en
afrique par exemple deux très bonnes
raisons donc pour que les chinois
organisent des manifestations massives
d'allégresse comme ici place tienanmen
hausse entre le pk il fallait faire
grosse impression il fallait que ça se
sache et bien c'est fait
wako fans et tous les dirigeants chinois
tiennent surtout leur tête tenait
absolument à ce que le maréchal se
rendent à leurs thèses à savoir la
guerre est inévitable inévitables contre
l'urss tito a réfuté cette quito quant à
lui tenait absolument à ce que ce voyage
historique le définisse lui et son pays
comme tout à fait indépendant à la ligne
soviétique
il pense à sa succession sur certains
plans mais pas tout à fait le même les
uns comme les autres considèrent que la
menace qu'elle quelle soit vient de
l'urss mais malgré ces convergences de
vue aucun communiqué commun n'a pu être
signé ce qui n'a pas empêché les chinois
d'invités quito à s'incliner devant la
dépouille mortelle de mode c'est tout
c'est la première fois qu'un chef d'état
pénètre dans le nouveau mausolée
monsieur giscard d'estaing a écrit à
monsieur thank you ping à l'occasion de
la nomination de ce dernier ouvre
nomination de ce dernier au poste de
vice-premier ministre de chine monsieur
giscard d'estaing qui avait rencontré
monsieur tian xiao ping à paris en 1975
il exprime son espoir de voir les
relations franco chinois se développer
en soulignant que l'existence d'une
chine forte et prospère favorise les
intérêts du las de la paix mondiale et
donc les intérêts de la france la paix
dans le monde c'est peut-être au
moyen-orient' qu'elle ne se jouer le
président de la république aura
l'occasion d'en débattre avec le roi
hussein de jordanie le souverain
hachémite arrivera demain à paris des
entretiens sont prévus à l'elysée pour
marty
hussein de jordanie 42 ans depuis 25 ans
sur le trône hachémite celui qu'on
appelait le petit roy vient juste de
fêter son jubilé d'argent 25 années de
règne au cours desquelles il a vécu
trois guerres israélo-arabes mené
pendant un an le combat contre les
fedayin dans son pays ait échappé à cinq
attentats les régimes arabes passent
hussein de jordanie reste mais se voit
menacer la nouvelle politique de
colonisation d'israël dans les
territoires occupés ne lui laisse guère
d'espoir de récupérer un jour la
cisjordanie qui appartenait à son
royaume
face à l'intransigeance des nouveaux
dirigeants israéliens hussein crainte
d'une flambée du nationalisme arabe qui
pourrait balayer les régimes modérés et
déclencherait une cinquième guerre au
proche orient
le roi hussein estime qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution sans le retour de la
cisjordanie et de gaza que les
palestiniens doivent pouvoir se
prononcer sur leur avenir et l'autorité
dont ils veulent dépend si israël ne
veut pas se retirer des territoires
occupés comme le demandent les
résolutions des nations unies
nous allons vers une crise très grave
pas dans l'immédiat coûte mais nous en
prenons le chemin feu hussein est de
nouveau un homme seul hostile aux
soviétiques déçu par les américains il
se tourne vers l'europe
et pour lui la france est le pays le
mieux placé pour de nouvelles
initiatives diplomatiques au proche
orient
les vacances sont terminées et je crois
qu'il est presque temps de songer
maintenant au prochain dans ce domaine
il y aura dès le 26 septembre prochain
d'ailleurs du nouveau le billet d'avion
londres new york pour moins cher
finalement que l'aller retour paris nice
en avions toujours londres new york pour
mille 180 francs c'est en effet ce que
propose le patron d'une compagnie
britannique de charters il s'appelle ce
patron fred les coeurs une initiative
d'une nation ne fait pas plaisir aux
autres compagnies aériennes obligée elle
aussi de réajuster leurs prix sur une
île où la concurrence est féroce
qui n'a pas rêvé de partir pour les
états unis sur un tel avion pour moins
de 12 cents enfants
c'est ce que propose près de l'ecr avec
son train du ciel au départ de
l'aéroport de stanstead à 70 km de long
ça ne sera pas un chanteur mais bien un
vol régulier
son idée est simple vous prenez votre
billet en montant dans l'avion comme au
guichet d'une qu'un à condition bien sûr
d'y trouver une place l'avion partira
une fois plein il n'y aura ni
réservation ni service à bord vie cinéma
mais seulement 11 vols par semaine en
été et 7 hors saison sur quatre décès
disent souvent embarqués chacun 3 145
passagers
ces restrictions sur le nombre des vols
ont été imposées par les autorités
américaines se réservant ainsi le droit
de proposer un système voisins cette
fois des etats unis vers le relais tout
ceci ne semble pas préoccupé outre
mesure les responsables de l'ecr airways
il prévoit pour la première année
d'exploitation plus de deux cent mille
passagers nous n'avons pas de bureau un
jeune afrique ou dans la 5e avenue
ainsi nous pouvons comprimer les
dépenses freier tendre un peu de
personnel 900 employés seulement nous
avons constaté qu'il y avait un marché
énorme sur l'atlanta nord et que ce
marché n'était pas satisfait par les
compagnies régulières avec leurs tarifs
trop élevés il a voulu t mac ratisser un
petit peu les transports aériens
oui évidemment il l'a démontré tease et
aux etats-unis 5 % seulement de la
population possède un passeport
nous pensons qu'il ya là bas un très
grand nombre de gens qui veulent voyager
et qui n'en ont pas les moyens
car les grandes compagnies proposent ce
qu'elle appelle un tarif apex où il faut
réserver 21 juin nous nous n'avons
aucune réflexion de cette sorte
et les gens peuvent rester aussi
longtemps qu'ils achètent simplement un
billet à stansstad airs pop pour aller à
new york où un bien meilleur pour venir
en angleterre
il a fallu cinq ans avec heures pour
obtenir une chose apparemment aussi
simple c'est parce que les grandes
compagnies réunies au sein d'une
association veulent sauvegarder leurs
privilèges établissant un tarif de base
les transporteurs bloquent leurs prix
que la ligne soit rentable ou
déficitaires reste que chacun essaie
ensuite à travers des tarifs
promotionnels d'augmenter son
coefficient de remplissage en proposant
un prix très bas les coeurs brugg les
cas et surtout risque de compromettre la
rentabilité de certaines compagnies
les compagnies sont très soucieuses de
ne pas compromettre leur rentabilité
comme vous le savez sur les lignes
atlantiques nord presque toutes les
compagnies perdent de l'argent
donc il s'agissait pas pour elle de
compromettre leur allait encore plus la
rentabilité actuelle mais au contraire
de l'améliorer et une façons de
l'améliorer
c'était accroître leur coefficient de
remplissage est de vendre à des prix
peut être légèrement inférieure
au prix actuel des sièges qui jusqu à
présent partie vide
c'est à l'évidence sous la pression de
l'ecr que les transporteurs ont baissé
leurs prix près de 300 francs pour
paname études ou blaga au départ de
londres soit un billet à 1300 francs
quant à air france son tarif minimal
passe de 1900 à 1700 francs reste que
les compagnies ont d'énormes frais
d'exploitation par rapport à la formule
est que la vente et la réservation des
billets et surtout comme sur ce vol air
france le service à bord le tout
représentant plus de 20% du prix du
billet lacker apparaît donc avant tout
comme un redoutable concurrent
d'abord par la clientèle qu'il vise non
une clientèle d'affaires -2 35% des vols
transatlantiques
mais les jeunes les étudiants et les
vacanciers toute une population
susceptibles de voyager d'une nouvelle
façon
d'autant que cette clientèle est
nécessaire aux grandes compagnies car le
nombre de personnes transportées
environ 5% de la population mais guère
extensive et puis ce que proposent les
choeurs sur les lignes nord américain et
d'autres pourraient leclerc sur d'autres
lignes transatlantiques
déjà les compagnies disent à qui veut
l'entendre que les coeurs ne tiendra pas
ce qui est sûr c'est que s'il réussit il
va introduire un nouvel art de voyager
et surtout si son expérience se poursuit
obliger les compagnies de repenser leur
politique commerciale
il était une fois l'amérique
un film qui va ouvrir dans quelques
minutes ce soir donc le festival de
deauville un film au titre bien banal et
qui est pourtant beaucoup plus que cela
en moins de deux heures ce sont en effet
des extraits de 83 film réalisé par 54
réalisateurs différents qui sont
présentés aux spectateurs base de ce
film cinq thèmes la terre la ville la
guerre l'américaine la famille autant
dire les cowboys les indiens les soldats
les repas de famille la ruée vers l'or
mais aussi les chômeurs les minorités
etc
seul absent de ce film finalement les
gangsters la mafia il est vrai est
d'origine sicilienne un portrait de
l'amérique donc mais tout de même en
costume du dimanche
chacun voulait une parcelle du pays on
pouvait l'acheter
on pouvait la volée et dans l'oklahoma
est lui-même une course pour la gagner
blige bono et sécurité cchs à madrid au
saut comme en europe
wissant biennale après les méchants
avaient chacun leur style
il était une fois l'amérique avec cet
extrait donc 2 go west la fume des marx
brothers le tiercé le 1 le 13 et le 4
voilà la combinaison qu'il fallait jouer
pour l'emporter cet après-midi dans le
prix de la table disputé à longchamp le
1 le 13 et le 14 c'est à dire full of
pop gran mogol et courteline les
rapports 2008 130 francs pour 5 francs
dans l'ordre et 566 francs toujours pour
5 francs mais dans un ordre différent
retour donc au cyclisme avec les
concurrentes pour le maillot de champion
du monde de cyclisme sur route qui sont
toujours sur leur vélo à caracas le
point jean michel le lion a le satellite
nous joue des petits tours l'image
décroche souvent mais quand même une
image de laurent au centième kilomètre
alors qu'il s'échappait depuis il a été
rejoint et il reste maintenant 100 km de
course on annonce les abandons de race
le hollandais bruyère le belge paolini
l'italien est de 3 français le jeu
berland campanaire arrivés vers 22h30 si
le satellite le vaut bien
ça fait du bien antenne de cours à vous
retransmettre en direct l'arrivée de ce
championnat du monde de cyclisme sur
route aux alentours de 22h30 22h46 le
satellite marche le temps demain du nord
de la bretagne à la frontière belge de
ciel sera assez nuageux et quelques
chutes de pluies sont possibles sur le
reste du territoire le temps sera
ensoleillé et assez chaud après
dissipation des brouillards matinaux qui
se formeront principalement du bassin
aquitain au massif central et au
nord-est
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminée après le cyclisme vers 23h30
donc c'est bernard rapp qui vous donnera
les dernières informations de ce
dimanche
bonne soirée